that Broadband availability is no longer
a luxury right it's something that
touches virtually every aspect of Our
Lives whether we realize it or not
increasingly we work online
um we we you know we educate our young
online we pay bills online we connect to
others online all of these things are
things that many of us in areas that are
well connected just take for granted
right this is just something we imagine
that everyone has
um but it isn't you know there are
millions of Americans that live every
day without those things
I'm Tyler Cooper I'm the editor-in-chief
at Broadband now this isn't just about
bringing people online to enjoy the
conveniences that the internet provides
it's about providing opportunities for
everyone to take advantage of all of the
benefits that sort of a connected world
has to offer and so you know those are
things like ensuring that education is
available to everyone in an equitable
way making sure that all students have
access to the same online tools and
programs that their classmates have
making sure that everyone has the
ability to find jobs and pay bills and
do all the things that we do online you
know where if you don't have those if
you don't have those tools life is
measurably harder so all of these things
are really sort of they need to be
foundational ideas we keep in mind when
we're talking about how to develop and
deploy this technology because again
it's it's not just about being able to
entertain ourselves and do the the you
know the things we love to do online
it's about making sure that we all have
opportunities to take advantage of the
digital era yeah this is something
that's that's a significant portion of
this obviously the bead grants focus on
infrastructure but then we also have the
the digital Equity act
um which you know in this case is going
to provide 2.75 billion dollars over the
course of a few Grant programs to you
know that it's really squarely centered
on this sort of digital Equity component
so making sure that everyone has the
capacity needed to sort of take
advantage of the full benefits of the
the digital economy
um so Nevada I believe is you know is
going to get around 750
to sort of fund activities Central to
this program things like you know
developing a Central State digital
Equity plan for Nevada specifically I'm
working with individual communities and
stakeholders to get communities engaged
and then also just doing data collection
from an adoption standpoint again we
have this wealth of data around where
Broadband isn't it is and isn't
available but we don't have very
granular data outside of organizations
like ours that provide like pricing
information affordability metrics and
just in terms of adoption how many
people are actually taking advantage of
the options they have available to them